jennifer zabasaja in new york city
thanks so much for joining us today
so the anticipation is finally over for
a lot of us
here in the city indoor dining is
finally set to resume
on wednesday september 30th in a limited
capacity
so for restaurants it means hopefully
promising results a better chance of
survival but our customers actually
ready to go
back inside that's what we wanted to
talk about of course because we're still
in the middle of a pandemic
which is why i asked bloomberg news food
editor kate crater
to be here with me today it's been a
long time i've seen you kate how's it
going
oh my gosh ready to get inside and start
eating for me
truly yeah i know i mean it's been
months so
i guess can you just take us through the
latest what's going on we saw some
protests on monday from several
restaurant tours
uh what's the latest what can you tell
us um i mean it's a very critical
situation
restaurants in new york are hanging by a
thread we are
one of the last if not the last city to
open for indoor dining
and ppp loans are running out for
a lot of these restaurateurs who don't
have who aren't sitting on a mountain of
cash
so it's a very very critical moment and
this indoor dining can't come soon
enough for a lot of them
yeah i mean were you surprised to see
some of the protests on monday
um those protests were really creative i
have to say um
and you know it's sort of it it's awake
and it looked it was kind of amusing to
look at but
i think it belies just how serious it is
i mean you see these signs 25
does not pay the rent and if you don't
have an accommodating landlord
these um these restaurants hers are in
very very critical situations
yeah totally which is why part of the
reason why we wanted to talk to you
was because this is such a big momentous
moment as you mentioned
uh and you and i actually were very
lucky to sit down with famed chef
and restaurateur andrew carmellini on
monday
uh to walk through sort of his plans for
indoor dining so
uh we're gonna give viewers a little bit
of a look at what we experienced
yesterday and ate so
let's take a look at our first bit of
that conversation
hopefully kind of the there's some light
in the tunnel with koben
uh you know from most restaurants or you
know hospitality
new york city especially after doing
this for 30 years
here on this island is that it's all new
because you can't do
private parties and you can't do indoor
uh you know you can't do
private events which is really kind of
like um
our there's the bread and butter of what
you do it's like the gravy
you know being able to like you know
whether it's corporate events
social events uh where you can maximize
your spaces
uh and maximize some profitability
can you say like for you like what the
numbers look like so you said well conde
verde has
110 seats yeah inside yeah it
would and so 25 you have
it's actually interesting we actually
have more seats outside at la conde
verde than we have inside right now
which we we're not able to do that at
the other restaurants uh for
their location or what corner we're on
or there's you know if you're in a bike
lane or a fire lane there's a million
different
kind of um you know provisions yeah but
so here we're actually doing some very
decent
volume because we have a good amount of
seats outside um which will go away once
it gets really really cold
so inside i think uh because we can use
our private dining room here for indoor
dining so i think we can do about 65
people
65 seats which is not enough to
you know long-term to make it a going
concern but it is enough to
have a core team here to be able to you
know
pay some rent keep the supplier you know
payments going uh i i won't be making
money my partners won't bring
money uh and it's just about making it
to next year
yeah so kate what what did you think
about that whole experience i mean
i love the food so oh my gosh i can't
even tell you
it's um i mean it's been i think outdoor
dining in new york city has been kind of
a gift it
has brought the city back to life in a
way it's certainly been a little bit of
a lifeline for a lot of these
restaurants
but um but you know even like andrew
carmellini was saying
he has more seats outside and he will
keep them open but at some point
even the most intrepid
blanket wearing blanket wearing
customers
are it's it might get too intense the
weather might get too cold
too snowy too slushy and you want to be
inside
so i thought i thought it felt fantastic
to be back inside in a very isolated
very safe
manner but there's something about the
immediacy of it
um you realize what you've missed and
you realize what we haven't had for so
long
so i i say welcome back yeah and
i mean you've been speaking with a lot
of restauranteurs are they
are they sort of in a similar situation
as andrew most of them are i mean some
of them
are if you have a small restaurant and
let's face it like you know some of your
favorite neighborhood restaurants
are probably not giant or probably small
and operating at 25
means maybe like 15 seats you know it's
not
and that those numbers just don't make
sense because you need
a minimum amount of chefs and staff
to staff it and to stop the place and
you know if you're basically one
one employee per customer those numbers
are never
going to work yeah and i feel like we
were also
talking about the future of the
restaurant scene right i mean
as you mentioned you know outdoor dining
has in some way become like a staple of
the city
um i don't know how it took so long but
um
i i was really curious to hear what the
two of you said about the future of
of dining here in the city let's just
take a listen to what andrew said and
we'll go from there
i think that this will forever change
the restaurant industry here
in the city or do you think once i don't
know
you get the vaccine people get back to
normal so to speak
that it will just revert back to the way
things were
that's a great question yeah it's a good
question you know it's it's it's hard
it's so hard to predict right and i
think that most of us were tired of the
you know is new york city ever going to
come back article or the you know
everyone's leaving new york
article and you know i've seen i've seen
that before and i think betting against
new york is a mistake
i mean history history history will
always you know prove that
so i think that it's gonna not gonna
happen one day it's gonna happen over
time and i think
things will come back to
it'll be adjusted and i think
that actually i hope that there's going
to be kind of like a
golden moment after this i'm using the
look yeah it's already see that there's
a lot of pent up demand
like after quarantine and i think uh you
know private dining events
social events um are going to really
kind of explode whether that's next year
or the year after i'm not really sure
and it depends on where the economy is
and how companies are spending
um but i'm i'm hoping for a gun of
golden age
you know kind of after this yeah
yeah no i think i think it would be it
would compound the tragedy if it didn't
change um the restaurant world i mean i
don't i think you're coming back
500 cosine on that like you're
never never going to be out and it's
coming back and it already has
i mean i feel like by the time that
story was printed it already felt dated
sure but um but it's it's a process i
mean it's a process
and new york was hit hard but um
i think that i do think this is going to
be a time
when even if landlords aren't all
renegotiating their leases right now
i think the smart ones are going to
figure out that they need restaurants
because there's not
it's not like retail is booming it's not
like you know
it's not like there's not a lot of other
options to put in there so even just out
of necessity
but i think it's also maybe going to
bring in some um
i i think it is unfortunately taking
some restaurants out of the game
but if they weren't doing well before
the pandemic it was time you know if you
weren't if you weren't
doing good business in like december 19
2019 then you shouldn't be in the
restaurant business really like that was
really like such a high flying
high flying time so i think it's going
to make some changes i think
structurally
hopefully this will address like
living wages for workers and just the
very fragile ecosystem that restaurants
were living in
and i mean it comes with there's pain
attached to that but
i do i think i think it's gonna change
restaurants i think here in new york
like the way outdoor dining now is going
to become like a fundamental part of the
way
people do things like it's going to be
really hard to take that away
in the next five ten years
and kate what was it about that december
2019
time period that you said you know that
was such a good time
for restaurants in the city what what
were you noticing at that time i mean it
just epitomizes
a time when people go out to celebrate
it's certainly
a time for restaurants in new york city
where they have
um peak events private dining spaces
parties and that's where restaurants
make the majority of their money it
doesn't happen in dining rooms it
doesn't necessarily happen at the
restaurant table
it happens at the bar and it happens in
the event space in the private dining
room
and so december 2019 when the economy
was
pretty was going pretty strong is a time
i've heard from some restaurateurs that
they can make a year
one-third of their um
annual revenue in december so if you
were having trouble in december and it's
a hard game if you're having
trouble in december then i don't know
how
you're possibly making things happen
right now
yeah and i feel like i mean each each
day
each week sometimes we're hearing of a
new restaurant
closing right um i wonder if that's been
surprising to you as someone who's
covered the scene here for years
i mean i think it's it's just so sad
when you realize how slim the margins
are
nobody i mean maybe there's a few
restaurants that are sitting on a
mountain of cash or really well funded
but most aren't you know a lot of these
people go into the business
because they like to because they have
hospitality
you know and they're blood and they want
to serve people and so that's what they
do
but you know the numbers so far there
were 25 000
restaurants eating and drinking
establishments in new york
last year and so far 10 300 have opened
for outdoor dining so that makes you
think that most of them
will be opening for indoor dining as
soon as they can hopefully
tomorrow on september 30th um but
that number is less than half the
restaurants that existed
and you do as you say jen like the
numbers you hear about a beloved
restaurant closing every day
and it's heartbreaking yeah and i mean
it's it remains to be seen how
widespread this is going to be right
because yeah far from over with this
pandemic obviously
yeah i know i think if it stays if we
stay at 25 percent um
past governor cuomo has hinted that he
will expand to 50
um by november first if that doesn't
happen
it's going to be a crisis i mean i think
we've seen
a lot of bad news we've heard a lot of
bad news it's going to get much worse
yeah and what is i mean is keith
signaling
anything at this point about what's
going to happen november 1st or
is it just it's something you know i
mean i think the message changes every
day
and a lot of a lot of the news and a lot
of the announcements have caught
um restaurateurs off guard both from
the governor's office in the mayor's
office and so for instance um
outdoor dining the expansion of outdoor
dining round
came somewhat unexpectedly last week
and also they're changing the rules on
propane heaters
which is good you know because then
people can stay warm and not freeze to
death outside in
december and january but most of those
heaters have already been snapped up by
restaurants and other cities who knew
that they would need them for outdoor
dining so
it's put it's you know this last minute
messaging is
really challenging yeah and i mean you
mentioned other cities
several other cities have been doing
indoor dining for for weeks now yeah
um and so and andrew actually has a few
restaurants outside of the city so we
were
able to ask him uh how he suggested
you have restaurants outside of the city
as we mentioned are you
taking any of the cues what you did in
baltimore and detroit
and implementing that here or are they
completely different
well i think having places outside the
city was
we're very fortunate that we kind of saw
and be able to diversify a little bit
locations because
um we had a chance to practice first
before we opened up in new york so
we were opened up two months early
earlier
in maryland and michigan so we've
already had our kind of coba
coven playbook uh in in place and we
were able to see what that means for the
numbers what that means for the guests
and
uh you know i think that um you know
with indoor dining there
we see what that feels like um and you
know like i said before i think it's
i think it feels good it feels seamless
because we've had that practice outside
how has the staff in these places
do they feel safe doing indoor dining or
is it
two things we said before we reopened
that were really really important
is that we won't succeed long term
unless we really make employees and
customers just feel good
and like it's it's less about where the
fork goes
or like if the wine glass is in the
right place and more about
how just someone feels and you have to
re you know read the table and
make sure people are feeling comfortable
and that's i would say from a service
standpoint it's kind of like an
untangible thing it's just like making
sure these people feel relaxed and
comfortable
um and that was in the beginning now
with outdoor dining and people going out
i think most people are beyond that
because it's gone out already they've
been to a couple of different
restaurants so they've kind of gone
through the drill we saw some employees
uh that uh juicy
some employees were cons concerned about
coming back to work uh and i think just
after they were you know they took the
subway
uh one time or they got an uber one time
and they were back a little bit and they
saw that okay real life is happening and
i can be part of it
and still feel safe and healthy it's
really really important um
but you know when we called you know our
teams back and said listen we're
reopening
uh we had a strong response from which
is that kind of what i was worried about
in the beginning is
just on the staffing level and people
were excited to get back to work and
they were
they were like me the quarantine was
like nice but it was
you know you kind of like to lose that
when you're when you're
28 years old or when you're you know 35
years old it's like you've got to you
want to have
you want to have that center that
purpose you know besides the finances
just
going to work um i think is it feels
good
so much of it is interactive too right
the experience
being the ambiance right yeah it's just
the the the physicality of
of you know the teamwork of it and uh
you know for
if you're good at what you do especially
if you're a chef you're you're you're a
maker right usually defined by
um defined by how nice
ravioli are on a day-to-day basis it's a
very tangible
you know thing and uh to be able to kind
of you know do that
it just um
that food was great kate i'm just like
reminiscing about
how amazing it was i'm so hungry right
now and i'm also wondering why i chose
to wear my
shirt with the drapiest sleeves to eat
out
that's my question right now
it worked though the food the food was
the centerpiece
um but do you i mean are are you ready
to go back
to dining indoors i mean i know you do
this for a living but
um are are you for sure ready to get
back inside
i mean that's that's such a big question
um
me i am you know i think that at a place
like la conde verde um i know
the steps they've taken i know what
they're doing to make people safe
and i've eaten in their outdoor
restaurants and so i know
what they're doing and and all the
precautions and so
i feel safe um i wouldn't just walk in
anywhere i think i'm going to do it on a
case-by-case
basis you know but like la bernadette
who didn't open for
outdoor dining is gonna be the first um
fine dining three-star restaurant to
reopen in new york tomorrow on september
20th and they
invested tons of money in some
ionic filter system that's the same one
they have a john hopkins hospital
and they just have installed it at the
un
and i do feel a degree i mean i feel
like
if you're if you're out in the world and
interacting a little bit now
um a place like that i i feel 500
well let me let me walk that back i mean
i feel
i feel like it's i i believe that they
are taking all the precautions
i think it's going to be a safe place to
eat and i'm psyched to go
and i think i think we have to get back
to
some sense of you know bringing the city
back and
i'm willing to try that i'm willing to
you know go to a place that i completely
trust like la conte verde like la
bernadine
and try indoor dining yeah and as i
think andrew mentioned to us yesterday
even if people aren't yet ready to go
inside like there's still these
restaurants are still offering
takeout in many ways so you can still
support yeah
no a lot of them have done such a good
job of changing their model
you know changing the model of how they
do business and um andrew was saying
that they never offered takeout at la
conde verde which is in tribeca because
people treat it like a neighborhood
restaurant
but you know like the number of cases
here in new york is ticking up ever so
slightly
and you have to take precautions just
because these places are open
if you don't feel safe going out to eat
no one like everybody should do what
they think
is the best thing for them yeah i mean
it's gonna
remain to be seen how this all plays out
um on a
daily hourly basis right yeah
i mean um yesterday was a really really
great day i'm obviously looking forward
to
indoor dining uh opening again but kate
please please come back and and check in
with us
let us know how it's going if you get a
chance to go out there i sure will
thanks jen thanks kate it was nice to
dine with you i know we'll do it again
indoors outdoors we'll do it yes safely
cheers
indoor cheers welcome back indoor dining
we need some wine now where's our
glasses of wine i know right it's time
um all right thank you everybody stan
thank you
thanks everyone spending some time with
us thanks everybody for tuning in
um and let us know what you think if you
get out to indoor dining
yep we want to hear yep see you next see
you next time